collègue la parole est à Madame Natacha
Bouchard pour le groupe UMP
oui madame la ministre mes chers
collègues je souhaite interroger le
gouvernement sur sa politique en matière
de soutien aux formations scientifiques
et techniques mis en place au sein des
universités de proximité dans les
territoires ma réflexion est inspirée de
la situation de l'ULCO l'Université du
Littoral et de la côte d'Opal que je
connais bien en tant que maire de Calais
cette université dont les antennes sont
implantées à Boulogne Calais dunkererque
et Saint-Omer a lancé en 2010 une école
d'ingénieur l'école d'ingénieur du
littoral cette structure à laquelle nous
tenons beaucoup compte 250 étudiants
recrutés à bac+ 2 qui sortent avec le
diplôme d'ingénieur après 3 années
d'études la carte universitaire est parf
par fois critiqué quand elle semble
répondre à des critères plus politiques
qu'à l'intérêt des étudiants mais
l'existence d'université de proximité
est un atout indéniable quand les
formations s'insèrent avantageusement
dans le tissu économique
territorial ainsi l'école d'ingénieur du
littoral souhaite développer son projet
pédagogique sur les métiers des flux de
l'énergie ou de la mer qui sont ceux de
l'avenir de not notre région encourager
ces cursus scientifiques et techniques
représentent un véritable enjeu pour
renforcer l'économie locale tout en
offrant des débouchés à nos étudiants ma
question sur ce point sera double d'une
part nous souhaitons savoir comment
l'État peut accompagner la montée en
charge de ces filières alors qu'elles
sont adossé au budget des universités de
proximité d'autre part comment
encourager l'apport de taxes
d'apprentissage vers ses formations dans
les territoires en effet quand
l'initiative locale est forte celle-ci
est concurrencée par les métropoles
régionales qui aspirent les financements
au sein de leur propre région pouvez
donc vous nous dire madame la ministre
nous indiquer quelle est la politique du
gouvernement pour soutenir ces filières
merci Madame la Ministre avez la parole
madame la sénatrice monsieur le
président madame la sénatrice merci de
de cette question il se trouve que je
suis allée à Boulogne et que j'ai
rencontré la communauté universitaire
ainsi que l'organisme de recherche if FR
en compagnie de Frédéric Hiler j'ai pu
voir à quel point les entreprises les
universités les laboratoires de cette
école d'ingénieur travailler ensemble
dans des domaines très divers que j'ai
découvert d'ailleurs pas seulement
l'agroalimentaire mais pas seulement le
campus de la mer comme ils se sont
prénommés dans sur cette côte d'Opal
c'est quatre s de la côte d'Opal mais
également dans le domaine des
cosmétiques par exemple don dans des
dans des domaines vraiment très divers
et il travaillent tout à fait
naturellement avec fluidité avec les
entreprise c'est dire que le partenariat
avec les entreprises via la taxe
d'apprentissage doit pouvoir se
développer pour qu'il puisse se
développer parce que çaela contribuera
aussi à augmenter le nombre de jeunes en
alternance et vous savez que je crois
beaucoup à l'alternance pour la réussite
étudiante la réussite étudiante étant
d'ailleurs dans cette université de
proximité hulco supérieure de 10 points
à la réussite étudiante moyenne
et bien il pvoir se former en
apprentissage votre université cette
école d'ingénieur doit se rapprocher
d'un centre de for d'un CFA d'un centre
de formation d'apprentis dans le
nordpcalé la plupart des formations
d'apprentissage en renseignement
supérieur sont gérées par le CFA
Formasup qui a l'habitude de travailler
des organisme de formation divers pour
le reste et pour répondre à
l'augmentation des effectifs et bien il
y a les contrats de sitite et le
ministère de l'Enseignement supérieur et
de la Recherche aura à cœur de donner
les moyens nécessaires à cette
université à cette école d'ingénieur
pour pouvoir continuer continuer à
insérer durablement dans le territoire
bien inséré dans le dans cet écosystème
qui a une dynamique qui lui est propre
et que j'ai pu encore une fois constater
de visu de façon à assurer la réussite
étudiante et l'insertion professionnelle
des étudiants
concernés merci Madame Bouchard
oui donc si j'ai bien compris je peux
donc faire réponse donc à toutes ces
antennes qu'il y aura un contrat de site
et concernant la taxe d'apprentissage
par rapport aux métropole il y aurait-il
une possibilité d'avoir une ponction sur
la ponction régionale pour qu'elle
revienne un peu au au
territoire localement parce que elles
aspirent beaucoup en fait de de
financement pour les villes centre de
métropole